Andrea sounds like there's a lot of hype
obviously surrounding the Model X and
your review of the car is that it lives
up to the hype yeah I loved it and I
kind of came at it as a woman and a mom
and so I decided to test drive the car
not as a stock analyst but as a
potential customer and I decided to test
drive it because I think it'll be the
safest car on the market we haven't
gotten the independent government review
yet but I think that will happen and
it's a very useful car and then when I
actually test drove the car I actually
really liked it now you don't cover the
other automakers though so how do you
model your valuations on a peer-to-peer
basis or something like Tesla yeah so my
Tesla valuation is based on this being
one of the fastest growing companies in
the world and creating a lot of value
very quickly so obviously we have a high
multiple I think they'll have about
twenty dollars worth of earnings power
in the year 2020 now of course the ramp
on how we get there not quite sure about
but that's how I value it and I also
value it sort of as a tech company in
addition to being a car company a tech
company you cover a range of other
companies including gun makers energy
equipment makers what are the
commonalities that a company like Tesla
whether it's an auto maker or a tech
company shares with these other range of
companies disruptive technology the
presence of the product on the market
disrupts the market and fundamentally
changes that market or changes human
behavior that's how I look at it
interesting because Scarlett one of the
big issues that's been around with Tesla
is that they're only going to sell about
500,000 units globally by 2020 versus GM
selling 10 million units this year so
it's hard to see how the valuation can
be so high that's sort of the idea in
the communion it's a niche car maker
through and through right now Andrew
what are your thoughts on Tesla's
ability to become a mass-market
automaker I think it's very good so
Tesla has solved the energy storage
problem so they're not really solving
the problem of driving they're solving
the problem of energy storage
electricity is a more efficient means of
using power and that's true
of anything it has nothing to do with me
being a stock analyst that's just
physics and so what's up but the reason
why we don't we use gasoline is because
that's how we store the car and get our
power in the gas tank so I we saw our
energy in the gas tank through gasoline
and so it has been really hard to have a
high-powered application for automotive
views through using electricity and
Tesla has solved that problem and now
they're taking that and not only
applying it to the auto market but
they're applying it to the energy
storage market as a means of storing
solar power and I think we're going to
see other product lines come out over
the future although I'd hate to
speculate on what those could be right
now so does that mean a better way of
looking at Tesla's like as a gigantic
battery company versus in a car company
in a way I mean this is a company that's
really innovative and is solving
problems that primarily have to do with
energy storage which as kind of as the
human species that's a big problem that
we all face right how do you store solar
power right we so that is how i see that
company and they are going to be
completely vertically integrated on
their cell production by the year twenty
twenty through their gigafactory which
is a joint venture with Panasonic that
will open in Nevada so if we're to look
at Tesla as this energy storage company
is it important is it critical for
Tesla's cars or i should say for Tesla
to be profitable when it comes to
selling those vehicles yes and that is
what this year 2016 is all about is
Tesla needs to prove to Wall Street that
they can make money on the bottom line
selling their cars not just on the gross
margin line so yes this is sort of the
year where I think they want to prove
that they can do that so that way when
they if they did and future years want
to come back to the capital markets to
raise more money people know that they
can make money selling the products that
they make if that makes sense well
there's a challenge there right because
us new vehicles are selling at a record
rate right now Alex have bought more
than 17 million plus at an annual rate
where does Tesla go if that starts a
plateau and drop off right so it's to
your point so does it matter if car
sales have peaked for Tesla well and
they haven't because Tess is a market
share play right so what Tesla did is
they went from let's say in 2012 selling
like 10 Model S's to in 2015
and selling more Model S's than and then
the Mercedes s-class this is in North
America the BMW 7-series BMW 5-series
the audi a8 so they went from like worst
to first in their category and so the
bet the long-term bet is that they can
do that with other types of cars the
Model X and then the model 3 which comes
out which debuts you can start taking
orders March 31st